ach das ist jung hat nichts
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zur fünften today show folge
zusammen mit trainer und wir haben die
fahrgäste dabei shop media die sich hier
in einem krieg befinden was irgendwie
vor der aufnahme passiert ist und ich
hab keine ahnung aber die produktivitäts
götter von gast gast vielleicht schlagen
sich neben weiter mit dem gar die skins
erfährst du dir immer noch nicht doch
waren sie bei dir funktioniert bei mir
funktioniert alles ach so ja wir hatten
nämlich wieder ein thema vorbereitet und
zwar also ihr seid ja unsere ersten
gäste und ihr helft den er erst mal beim
bauen bzw baut euer eigenes haus und
jeder macht was ihr fällig und wir
werden dabei mal ein paar tränen
quatschen das heutige thema ist von logi
/ l und der frage würdet ihr euch eher
für gleichberechtigung oder umweltschutz
einsetzt oder naturschutz sie er kommt
drauf an gleichberechtigung von wem
ja weil sie nicht von grauen jacke oder
schwarzem oder von ja sogar schon geahnt
von randgruppen
wir müssen jetzt erstmal ein bauplatz
suchen und wird das ja wohl nichts ein
bauplatz suchen von also um allgemein
sagen wir mal
naja da also da muss man differenzieren
also es ist nämlich so gut finde ist so
was wie eine frauenquote ist unnötig
unnötig nervös überlegt euch mal guckt
mal ihr seid so in einem unternehmen und
eure vorgesetzte ist eine frau und ist
er ist ja nichts schlimmes dran aber
dann wenn die heiße ware hilft dann
heißt es immer dass ist die quotenfrau
dann kann ich könnte dich geht nicht so
respektieren wie ich der frau
respektieren würde die auf herkömmlichen
weg da reingegangen ist es ist hier
können frauen auf einem herkömmlichen
weg findet es geht zum beispiel alle zum
beispiel dieses bmw frau
ich finde das einfach nur geglaubt
gebügelt die alles einfach geehrt ich
hoffe aber zum beispiel bei yahoo um
beim internet direkt zu sein die neue
yahoo -chefin jeder vor bei google
ich nahm gar nicht weiß die hatte er
auch ein multi dollar job dem
multimillionen dollar job bekommt ja
also jetzt kommt als auch an naturschutz
ist natürlich auch wichtig meine soviel
wieder immer abgerundet wird und dinge
zerstört werden in der natur aber ich
weiß als erreicht wird ich glaub ich
würd mich für gleichberechtigung
einsetzen weil von boll denkt sich ich
werde mich naturschutz einsetzt könnte
ich ja gleich vegetarier werden ich mich
nämlich ziemlich gleich berechtigt und
der scheint so luft bringt einem das
selbst mehr aber selbst los sein
das bringt dir den naturschutz wer also
mal kurz abstimmen wert für naturschutz
ich habe die frage nicht verstanden oder
sich gegen gleichberechtigung wenn
allein idol hat also ihre drei wert für
naturschutz
ich ärgere mich das geht nicht
jetzt lasst uns ein bauplatz finden an
dahinten am schluss dass du hierbleiben
unten am fluss
also ging der shop media baut sich
wieder ganz hart wird eine auf und
gewann das nur aus er war die reden so
viel also viele leute reden alle einmal
ruhig ihr baut euch so um uns rum
irgendwie so dazwischen weil das ist
montiert und der mitte von dem flett
damit ihr wort nicht so rum rom neuer
dna ist genug abstand technik support
das locker genug abstand
was ist das hier der sport da schon
ich mache einfach mal genau
kilian genau und ob er in der 95
übrigens bitte nicht meckern falls wir
das nicht so toll hinkriegen also bauen
also den und ich weiß
650 bauen darauf folgt jeder handicap
fertig so also bäume hier könnte man
natürlich haus am see baut mini designer
haut oder die designer hut mit low ist
mein holz mittel sehen mit drei level
runter ich habe euch entdeckt als ihr
dieses eine komische haus da gebaut habt
von aus einer zeitschrift oder auf
unserer internetseite aus münchen ein
bisschen aufwendig ein bisschen sehr
großes wochenende feststehen ob das
ganze stattfindet das hätte uns
natürlich beim weit mehr gefordert aber
wollen wir wirklich mit ihrer kunden
nach 1 notiert verhaltens erste die
steine werden kaputt geschlagen
in seinem laden sowie im all geben ich
brauche ein bisschen stein firma
baumaterialien ich auch wenn gleich was
mit geben dann ja ich bin gleich was mit
und zwar so ich würde sagen wir sollten
höchstens einen blog über dem fluss
level sein wie das hat also das einfach
einfluss level sein
der menschliche bagger macht sich bereit
menschliche bagger und maler an die ak
ferrari und der menschliche 3d
spezialist ihr habt ihr jetzt sogar neue
bäume gepflanzt ist ja ein gutes
beispiel
der naturschutz wie gesagt wir fangen
gleich an wer a sagt muss auch b sagen
richtig
selbstverständlich weiß wie das leben
wer a sagt haben wird auch wir sagen
können da los das ist ein duales und 2c
ich gern zeit nicht schöne zeit und
kraft habt ihr meine schaufel also die
reine ja wie denn irgendwie a sagt muss
auch b sagen können ja ich habe ja nicht
meine aufgabe mich hat nicht
ich habe auch die fein gesucht du bist
bei mir ganz nah
franken was du hast gar nicht oder zwei
wie hitler alles verloren
ob sie die jungs schon irgendwo eine
wüste haben wir haben klar wir haben
schon eine wüste gebaut gebaut hast du
ihn ich habe mir drin hesselink star
gesehen
kingstons kwh ist das zum sumpf er habe
ich gesehen habe ich gesehen wichtiger
lebensraum für viele in wismar
ausführliche platz wir brauchen ja nur
besser raus warum wird haus am see oder
seiner maße ärgerlich konnten zu hause
mini designer und machen obwohl im haus
ansehen können wir alle drin wohl nie
seine hood.de essplatz technisch steht
also garantiert dann gehe ich mal
schnell clay besorgen schnell besorgt
uns los das waren jetzt noch mal die
frage von dem die al asmar den stall das
war naturschutz oder gleichberechtigung
wie schon gesagt haben wir schon mal
antwortet ja aber unendlich sollen die
frage sein wenn man sie wenn man sich
entscheiden muss entweder wir haben acht
jahre man sich entscheiden muss man darf
sich für eine sache halt saga studenten
und dahin ob man ihm die einerseits für
den begriff enthalten welche
gleichberechtigung der natur am ende
dann aber auf jeden fall mehr sollte
wählen dürfen wer hier politiker wird
und so weiter oder was ich spende für
die natur weil ich kann jetzt nicht
spenden an alle schwarzer dass die noch
metacount und erzählt ein bisschen
frauen sind besser und viele und hier
alle männer sind doof soll ich nein ich
sage mal dass zum beispiel
irgendwo in ländern wo eine diktatur
herrscht dass du da dann irgendwie diese
diktatur entweder weg machen könnte so
meinst du die batterie ändern könnte ist
oder daß du quasi dafür sorgt dass der
regenwald nicht mehr so doll abgerundet
wird an einigen stellen
klipp und klar pflegen wird du bist ja
es gibt so viele länder mit diktatur
gegen eine schwarze ich hoffe für euch
ihr bereite den boden für wh zeigt druck
ja richtig ist auch so macht der crafter
richtig dampf schaufel hätte wird das ja
schneller vorangehen brauchen einfach
dass dem motto zum zum herzen hier
wenn man a sagt muss man auch nicht
gleich wieder der nun die fliegenden
kiste nichts verteilt auch treppen
ausblicks oben als dach ja und dann
besprechen wir noch nicht auch mal hier
wie das bauen ist soll einfach irgendwie
aus dem richtig weiß wohl was euer
problems ihr habt halt die themen im amt
ist man extrem produktiv teilweise ein
ich bin einfach nur doof ist so das amt
für er sich wenigstens ein danke für
eure unterstützung
ich weiß das zu schätzen
loewe hat sein recht schwerer zeit
müsste wissen seine tage damit schwere
zeit keine gleichberechtigung sein leben
ich glaube ich auch das ist scheiße
gelaufen
es ist scheiße wir müssen übrigens
schafe finden wenn ihr schafft findet
sagt manuela respekt ich habe zwei wert
gar nichts ich hab das haus dies dass
keller mit komischer wand obendrauf
pianist letzte stufe wir brauchen unser
haus hat eine fläche von 17 18
ob dreher kaputt war ich gemacht immer
noch falsche habt ihr act wurde die uns
quasi leiden kettet ganz paar soley
kohle nehmen kölner tauschen ja kommen
sie ja ich tausche auch wegen wolle
ich könnte euch dreck geben heutigen
dreck kursen also was er dafür als
bekommst also unglaublich wenn ihr hier
schlafen würde die würde da so gewählt
machen müsste nur einmal los hin und
dann nie so scharfen finden warum ich
amerikanischer beides hausblatt waren
keine landschaft dafür
er war kein einziges blatt da war kein
einziges schaaf ist ein schwein
ich glaube jetzt einfach mal rum und
coco bischöfe sind
ich hoffe ich finde zurück und es macht
hier dürfen keine monster computer das
schaffst du schon bald das gefühl dass
es ausgestellt weil ich habe noch keinen
getroffen der rhein die waren die wahlen
werde keine spinnen gesehen und alles
er wandte er sich wenig in der schafe
mein gott das ist dass die habe ich dir
jetzt gezeigt und ich hab jetzt gefunden
darin bucks kann der stein kein stein
mehr
das ist auch eine kur und die macht muh
die blöde kuh macht muh muh jj flecken
schnell macht nicht einfach
die machten pudding der hat flecken die
kamera lächeln und auch die sind ja gar
nicht viel sagen verwandten und feuer
will ich das neue abenteuer
wie ihr seht meine lieben zuschauer ich
sehe da gar nichts weil ich keinen plan
haben sie nichts wer der sorge sagt inga
matthes gesagt im fernsehen tv keine
schweine schafe die sonne immer in der
savanne eigentlich kann es seien also da
vermehrt wenn ihr euch schon hier in
dieser partie hätte ja vorher evakuieren
müssen ob sie auch schafe gibt ja dass
ich hab's vergessen dass die evaluieren
was gab kein prüfstand ziemlich
suboptimal den die komplette planung mit
denen heute lieber mit kriegen müssen in
der skype enthaltung von vorher klar ja
ich mache gar nichts drauf aber ich
finde einzige was gemacht haben
verstanden oder nehmen ja wenig sagen
wir schon mal ein anteil von einem ein
bisschen haus hier
ich hatte schon besseres gefühl ist ein
krieg ist zerstört und hat wirklich
könnt ihr schon mal was mit holz mal so
ich mache den grundriss und macht auch
die fläche größer und besorgt wächst die
angst für ein ordner es beispiele für
zimmermann nein will die folge ist er in
einer minute schon wieder auf den hunger
aber den politikern zur beruhigung ein
thema zur beruhigung warte ich kenne ich
die kanäle frei gestalten
also was soll die frage stellen er warf
der beruhigung verstehen eine riesige
hallo welches dieser
musikinstrumente hat die meisten seiten
violine b benji lautet die gitarre
was war das was man sie laute alarm